So, da bin ich wieder.
Wir probieren heute mal was aus.
Gucken, ob das taugt.
Und gucken, ob das ohne irgendwie App Store Registrierung oder hast du nicht gesehen, funktioniert.
Ich habe noch keine große Ahnung.
Ich habe nur vorhin gesehen, dass die ein öffentlich verfügbares SDK haben.
Für Garmin-Uren und für die Garmin-Fitness-Uhren und für die Fahrradcomputer und sowas.
Und ich bin ja gestern eine Runde Fahrrad gefahren und ich habe mir gedacht, so eine Sache wäre cool.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob ich sowas selbst programmieren kann.
Mal schauen, wie das funktioniert. Ich bin mal gespannt.
Mon KS.
Wir machen schon mal die VM an.
Ist Twitch richtig gecheckt, dass der Stream online ist?
Aktuell, weiß ich nicht, neun Leute.
Da hat Twitch auf jeden Fall noch keine Notifications.
Wir machen mal den Stream an.
Arch, by the way, erst mal eine Runde Package-Updates und dann gucken wir mal.
SebiDev, moin.
Ich glaube, jetzt hat Twitch kapiert, dass der Stream online ist.
Kernel-Update dabei.
Ah, dann können wir es so lassen.
Moment, das muss ein bisschen advanceder sein.
Was wir machen, ist folgendes.
Zumindest was wir probieren werden, ist folgendes.
Guckt mal.
Nehmt mal.
Bei deinem Kinderarzt lief Asciiquarium. Ernsthaft?
Also nehmt mal beispielsweise so einen Garmin-Fahrrad-Computer hier als Beispiel.
Da gibt es ja solche.
Also die Bilder davon sehen nicht so aus wie in der Realität.
Äh, Datafield.
Ja doch, da oben. Hier, hier, hier sieht man es ganz gut.
So, guck mal. Also guck mal, Leute.
Es gibt, es gibt.
Es gibt auf Garmin-Uhren und generell auf Garmin-Geräten solche Customizable-Layouts, wo man Data-Fields reinpacken kann.
Und diese Data-Fields kann man mit dem Garmin-SDK selbst entwickeln.
Beziehungsweise man kann auch komplette Apps für das Ding entwickeln.
Und das will ich mal ausprobieren, weil, ich zeige euch auch mal warum, nicht wirklich, ja so ungefähr.
Das ist ein ganz gutes Beispiel, guckt mal.
Also, wenn du die Navigation-Funktion benutzt, dann hat man, okay man hat hier eine Anzeige für den Berg.
Das hat man nicht immer, weil man sieht mal von der Karte nichts.
Aber, Garmin erlaubt, hier oben...
Hier unten nur zwei Customizable-Data-Fields.
Und das ist ein bisschen wenig, ja.
Also, ich hätte schon ganz gerne, auch wenn ich die Karte auf habe, hätte ich sowas wie Geschwindigkeit, Herzfrequenz.
Und die Herzfrequenz muss ich gar nicht haben.
Es reicht mir eine Anzeige mit der Farbe oder eben halt auch einen Timer oder irgendwie sowas.
Also, mehr als zwei Data-Fields da unten wäre schon ganz cool.
So, und was ich mir gedacht habe, was wir ausprobieren können.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das, ob und wie das funktioniert.
Wir können ein großes Custom-Data-Field bauen, was wiederum die anderen Daten in etwas kleiner anzeigen kann.
Dass das prinzipiell funktioniert, habe ich schon gesehen im Garmin-Store, dass es da sowas gibt.
Aber ich habe mir gedacht, man kann ja mal probieren, das selbst zu bauen.
Welche Smartwatch?
Also, ich habe eine Forerunner 255, auf der kann man das auch ausprobieren.
Aber mir geht es hauptsächlich um den Fahrradcomputer für Data-Field.
Aber auf der Uhr geht es genauso.
Letztendlich ist es aber auch egal, weil das funktioniert auf beiden Geräten.
Hoffe ich mal zumindest.
Wie gesagt, ich will ein Data-Feld machen, was im Kleinen mehrere Data-Fields anzeigen kann.
Das wäre natürlich sehr praktisch.
Vielleicht ein bisschen schlecht lesbar.
Aber auf jeden Fall besser, als die Informationen gar nicht drauf haben.
Also, aktuell Android? Nein, nicht Android.
Wie kommst du auf Android?
Das läuft auf den Garmin-Geräten, das ist irgendein Embedded-Zeug.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich glaube, man muss das sogar in C++ programmieren.
Das wird was.
Komm, wir machen mal ein bisschen was anderes.
Das hatten wir doch letztens.
Epic Chill-Step-Collection.
Was machen wir denn?
Komm, bisschen wupp wupp.
Also, das Garmin-Zeug, könnte ich wetten, ist kein Android.
Das ist so customisable und das wirkt so low-level, dass ich, ich könnte wetten, dass es nicht Android wird.
Das ist irgendwas spezielles von Garmin.
Was auch das heißt, dass es nicht Android wird.
Das muss doch dazu passen, wir...
Äh.
Äh, wo kommt die Musik her?
Cake Wait, Alter.
Das würde auch widersprechen, dass das Android VR ist.
Oder VR ist, weil das irgendein Custom-Garmin-SDK braucht.
Ich weiß nicht, wie advanced die sind.
Ob die einen Device-Emulator haben, ob ich dann meine Uhr per USB anschließen muss oder den Fahrrad komme.
Beides hier liegen.
Äh, glaub ich. Ja, beides hier liegen. Ne, die Uhr nicht.
Aber den Fahrrad-Computer hier liegen.
Um das auszuprobieren.
Ich bin mal, ich bin mal gespannt, ob das funktioniert.
Also, mein Ziel ist es, ein Custom-Data-Field zu bauen.
Ähnlich zu dem hier.
Warte mal, ich hab nämlich sowas gefunden.
Und das war eine super, super nice...
Super nice Idee, aber mit der Umsetzung bin ich nicht ganz zufrieden.
Also, ich will sowas ähnliches bauen.
Kann man das hier nicht nach Trending oder sowas sortieren?
Warum ist die, warum ist die Web, die Web-Ausgabe für diesen Shop...
So...
So kacke.
Also, ich würde gerne was installi...
Also, ich würde gerne was machen, ähnlich...
Zu dem da.
Genau.
Hier, das ist ein gutes Beispiel.
Guck mal.
Der Dude hat genau das gleiche gebaut.
Das hier unten ist ein Custom-Data-Field.
Also, wenn ihr das hier seht.
Der hat einfach ein großes Feld gemacht,
wo er selbst in klein Sachen anzeigen lassen kann.
Sowas in der Richtung.
Will ich auch bauen.
Nur, dass ich nicht so viele Sachen anzeigen möchte.
Und einfach...
Mich interessiert auch einfach, wie das funktioniert.
Ja.
Nur, dass ich nicht so viele Sachen anzeigen will.
Weil die werden zu klein.
Ich hab das von...
Ich hab das Data-Field von dem hier mal ausprobiert.
Das ist mini.
Du kannst kaum was erkennen, wenn er normal auf dem Fahrrad drauf sitzt.
Dafür passten hier 6 Felder hin.
Anstatt wie offiziell bei Garmin nur 2.
Also, ist schon...
Ist schon...
Ist schon ne coole Sache.
Und ich wollte mir das eh mal angucken, wie das funktioniert.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Nein, das ist...
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass das nicht Android-Wir ist.
Aber das ist...
Das ist da way.
Nee, das ist das Ziel heute.
Kann man auf dem Fahrradcomputer Docker laufen lassen?
Nee.
Ich geh mal ganz stark davon aus,
dass es auch noch nicht mal auf Linux-Basis ist,
sondern irgendein Embedded-Ding.
Ich hab ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung,
ob man da irgendwie was weiß.
Guck mal, ob man irgendwie was weiß.
What's the CPU?
Ja, zeig doch mal her.
Custom Socks.
Okay.
Also, man hat keine Ahnung.
Man hat...
Okay, man hat keine Ahnung, was in den...
Was in den Dingern drin ist.
Wisst ihr, man hat keine Ahnung.
Nicht FireRunner.
Also, man...
Okay.
Okay, von 2016.
Das bringt nix.
Benchmark Results.
Wie die machen Benchmarks auf ihrer Uhr?
Schraub mal auf.
Nee, nee, nee.
Also, man hat, glaube ich, echt keine Ahnung,
was da drin ist.
Ach, hier! Armkiste.
Zumindest...
Zumindest in der Phoenix-Uhr.
Ich glaube nicht, dass da gescheit
Android draufläuft.
Keine Ahnung, was da drauf ist.
Letztendlich ist es aber auch vollkommen egal,
was da drauf ist.
Weil wir werden das offizielle SDK von denen verwenden.
Also...
Das könnte ich mir... Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen, dass es das sogar gibt.
Ohne Scheiß.
Doom gibt es überall.
Wartet mal.
Doom.
Wobei...
Moment, das ist nicht Doom.
Das ist, glaube ich, einfach... Ach, das ist nur...
Nee, okay. Es ist gar nicht Doom.
Es ist einfach nur die Zahlen
des Fonts, der Doom-Font.
Aber,
ey, mich hätte es wirklich nicht gewundert,
wenn... Ja, vorbei.
Keine Ahnung. Also, mich hätte es wirklich nicht...
Nee, nee, nee.
Mich hätte es wirklich nicht gewundert, wenn es Doom auf der Uhr gibt.
Also, möglich wäre
das wahrscheinlich.
Ich meine, Doom läuft auf dem Schwangerschaftstest.
Wobei, das war
nur Fake. Aber trotzdem.
Also, mich würde es echt nicht wundern,
wenn da irgendeiner Doom zum Laufen
bekommt auf der Uhr.
Garmin Watch Doom.
Siehste? Siehste, es gibt schon Leute.
Data Field
von Ga...
Ach, nee, nee, okay.
Naja, also...
Also, das würde mich nicht wundern,
wenn es das gibt. Durchaus möglich,
dass irgendwelche verrückten Leute
auf ihrer Garmin-Uhr
es laufen lassen haben.
So, also, probieren wir das mal aus.
Es gibt irgendwo ein offizielles
Garmin SDK.
Ich mache mal einen Snapshot.
Nee, das kriege ich
nicht hin. Ich mache mal einen Snapshot von meiner
VM. Warum habe ich da so
viele Snapshots gerade?
Ah, nein.
Snapshot 2 und 3, aber
Snapshot 1 gibt es nicht.
Warum genau habe ich hier nochmal
gesnapshottet?
Ach so, wegen Mojo-Installation.
Ich glaube... So, machen wir
das mal weg. Snapshots verbrauchen. Gerade umso
älter sie werden, umso größer das Diff wird,
wir brauchen Snapshots. Immer unsinnig
viel Speicherplatz.
Auf, geh weg. Siehste?
Ist schon ein bisschen größer, der Snapshot.
Snapshoot.
Forever.
Also, let's go.
Erstmal das SDK
runterladen. Get the Connect
IQ. Siehste, die wissen schon mal Bescheid.
Only 5 Header.
Hey Max. Moment, was?
Hey Max, bin seit 1.9.
Das ist quasi seit einem Monat.
Pog.
In der Ausbildung zum Fachinformatiker
Anwendungsentwicklung. Wollte mich bedanken,
dass du mich dafür begeistern kannst.
Ja, das ist nice. Ich hoffe, dir gefällt's.
Wie war so der erste Monat?
Schon ein Plan, was deine App können soll.
Ja, ich hab das ja gerade eben
gezeigt. Ich will sowas hier in der Richtung bauen.
Also nicht mit der Map und so.
Also, es gibt auf den
Fahrradcomputern, auf den Uhren gibt es so
customizable data fields.
Und gerade
was mich ein bisschen nervt, ist auf der
Map-Übersicht kann man nur 2 data fields
einblenden. Und ich wollte
sowas ähnliches bauen, wie der Dude hier.
Der quasi ein custom data-Feld gebaut hat,
in dem er selbst wiederum kleinere data fields
anzeigt, sodass quasi
anstatt 2 in diesen
Space hier, dann 6
Stück passen. Nur, dass mir das hier so nicht gefällt,
weil es doch sehr klein
und pixelige Schrift ist.
Mir würden ja 3 Stück reichen.
Oder sagen wir mal vielleicht 4.
Da hat man ein bisschen mehr Platz.
Und außerdem interessiert mich
einfach nur
wie das funktioniert.
Ich glaube aber nicht, dass wir heute da wirklich
was sinnvolles auf die Reihe kriegen.
Ich muss erstmal das Garmin SDK runterladen
und dann guck mal hier. Also, da steht doch wie das
funktioniert hier. Install SDK.
Launch SDK
Manager bla bla bla.
Installing... Moment, was?
Monkey C.
Haben die nen eigenen
C-Dialekt, um den Kram zu programmieren?
Was zum Teufel ist
Monkey C?
Ich mein, Holy C würde
ich ja noch verstehen.
Okay, hat mit C anscheinend gar nichts zu tun.
Das Buch ist ja äußerst beliebt.
Nein.
Poggers Buch.
Okay.
Download and accept for Linux.
Das ging aber schnell. 3,2 MB?
Das ist...
Blazingly fast embedded Kram.
Nicht
Repos. Downloads.
Garmin.
Pog.
So.
Da wurde es entpackt.
Und was muss man jetzt machen?
Launch SDK Manager
from chosen download location.
Also wahrscheinlich das hier.
Okay, was?
Webkit GTK.
What? Ernsthaft?
Okay.
Webkit GTK.
Im Prinzip ist es wahrscheinlich
wirklich nur...
Hätten sie auch Elektron machen können, oder?
Ja.
Accepted ihr auch die
Terms of Service?
Also ich find die Terms of Service sind schon sehr nice.
Och nee.
Alter.
Das funktioniert
nicht.
Ja, das ist schon mal scheiße.
Wie soll ich...
Ich vermute mal, hier ist ein User
Feld. Hier ist ein...
Passwort Feld.
Und hier ist ein...
Okay, das...
Okay, Leute, es könnte schon mal scheitern.
An ganz grundlegenden Sachen.
Webkit GTK.
Kann ich vielleicht
noch was anderes installieren?
Was ist denn das?
242?
2...
411?
Legacy? Legacy?
Wobei, nee, wir brauchen Webkit
GTK 2...
Äh...
Ähm... Ja, ich weiß, das ist
das habe ich eben installiert.
Also mein GTK
Theme ist eigentlich legit.
Ähm...
NWG Look.
Okay, ich ändere mal mein
Theme.
Machen wir...
Wir machen das Default Theme.
Guck mal hier, Icons.
Und Icons...
Wir machen mal das Default Theme hier.
Nee.
Okay.
Als Flatpack User ausführen.
Was? Gibt es das als Flatpack?
Okay, das funktioniert
nicht.
Das geht schon... Das geht schon gut los.
Das ist weiße Schrift auf
weißem Hintergrund. Ja, würde ich auch so sehen.
Ähm...
Leute, ich...
Ich sehe irgendwie, dass das nichts wird.
Ähm...
Also...
Okay, Moment, Moment.
Webkit GTK
White. Wir suchen mal danach.
White Text und White Background. Alles klar.
Okay.
Aha.
Was?
Was zum Teufel interessiert mich?
Evolution. Das...
Ähm...
Das ist das E-Mail-Programm.
Okay, das ist wohl ein Known Bug.
Oder sowas. Fixed.
Nee, es ist Fixed.
Ähm... Okay, ich habe eine
Idee, was wir machen.
Ich habe eine Idee, was wir machen.
Webkit GTK.
Wir aninstallieren das nochmal.
Und jetzt...
Das hatten wir gerade installiert, ne?
Nee, das ist immer noch installiert.
Hä?
Okay, Webkit GTK.
Was hatte ich eben installiert?
Das hier. Das hier hatte ich
installiert.
Dann installieren wir doch einfach mal das hier.
Vielleicht funktioniert das aus irgendwelchen
Gründen besser.
Warum hat das vor allem die gleiche Versionsnummer?
Ich hatte alle drei
installiert. Wirklich? Ach, Moment.
Wir brauchen auch noch das Vierer.
Ach, Shit.
Äh, Gott.
Geht schon.
Geht schon gut los.
Dann installiere ich jetzt einfach das da aus dem
aus dem Auer.
Ohje, wenn man
ein Webkit selbst
kompilieren muss, das dauert doch bestimmt jetzt drei Stunden,
oder? Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal. Ich weiß nicht,
wie schnell man ein Webkit selbst kompilieren kann.
Und...
Ja, das ist aber
eine VM.
Und Browser-Kompilieren dauert immer drei,
dreieinhalb Stunden.
Weil vielleicht geht das ja hier gerade. Schauen wir mal.
Schauen wir mal.
Es ist ja gar nicht gesagt, dass es danach tut.
Lass uns lieber noch mal kurz googeln, was das Problem
ist.
White Background.
Wir suchen einfach
nach GTK
no content.
Ja, nice.
Ja, angeblich
wurde das ja gefixt, ne?
Das bringt mir nur jetzt nicht allzu viel.
Kann man
irgendwie Disable
Hardware Acceleration oder so?
Vielleicht liegt das
daran, dass der irgendwie komisch rendert?
Web... Okay, was?
Webkit Force... Okay, Moment.
Was? Webkit?
Webkit Force
Composition Mode. Force
Accelerated Compose to be always
on, to be always
off.
Jetzt das... Oh, das wird gebastelt,
Leute, ich sag's euch.
Okay, Webkit Kompilieren läuft.
Die volle
Open Source Linux Developer
Experience heute.
Also ich geb dem mal fünf
Minuten Zeit.
Wenn er dann nicht fertig ist, dann lass ich's
bleiben und installiere das andere wieder
und wir probieren mal die
Environment Variables
aus.
Ob die was machen.
Ach so, wie sieht's eigentlich aus? Hessen
mal 2023
Hochrechnungen.
Mal gucken, ob der Markt das regelt
oder nicht.
Ergebnisse.
Okay, CDU 35%.
Wir hatten Vergleich
zum letzten Mal vielleicht.
Okay, Grüne minus SPD, Grüne CDU
massig plus AfD plus FDP
minus. Oh nein.
Der Markt regelt doch nicht.
Ich hoffe, der Markt
regelt noch.
Zumindest über 5%.
Oh, was jetzt?
Das wollte ich nicht.
Ja,
zum Glück, vielleicht hängt's an meiner
Stimme am Ende, dass es wird
oder nicht. Was ist schlimmer, Garmin
Monkeys See oder Mon... Weiß ich nicht.
Ich konnte bis jetzt beides ja nicht ausprobieren.
Atheno, Dankeschön für den Sub.
Hab ich komplett übersehen. Sorry, falls
irgendwie noch jemand übersehen hat, aber ich glaub nicht.
Stimmt, wie sieht's
in Bayern aus?
Bayern Wahl
2023.
Hochrechnungen.
Die
CSU liegt vorne. Ja, das ist Bayern. Da liegt
die CSU immer vorne. Das geht gar nicht.
Das ist Patty Falls so.
Okay, um 19.06
gab's CDU, äh, nein,
sorry nicht CDU, CSU ist es ja in Bayern.
36%.
Ah, der Markt regelt nicht in Bayern.
Die AfD einfach mal die Hälfte fast von
der CSU.
Okay, die komische Bayern-Partei ist nicht am
Start. Und die Freien Wähler
gehen auch gut ab, immer in Bayern.
Wie sieht denn die Regierung aktuell in
Bayern aus? Ist das CSU und Freie Wähler?
Glaub schon, oder?
Keine Ahnung, was in Bayern abgeht.
Hessen interessiert mich mehr.
Boah, ey, ich hab keinen Bock
Webkit beim Kompilieren zuzugucken.
Das geht auch
so langsam. Wenn ich
das jetzt abbreche, hab ich so ein halbkompiliertes
Webkit auf der Platte.
Wobei das nicht schlimm ist, ich hab ja einen Snapshot
gemacht. Okay,
ich lass das da oben mal kurz kompilieren,
das stört ja nicht großartig.
Installieren wir nochmal Webkit
GTK. Das da
brauchen wir. So wie es aussieht.
Fünf, fünf brauchen wir, ne?
Webkit GTK.
So, und jetzt
setzen wir, was war das?
Webkit Disable
Composition Mode.
Auf 1. Nicht auf True, auf 1.
Wobei das eigentlich aufs Gleiche rauskommen muss.
Bin Garmin...
What? Hab ich doch grad installiert.
Das muss ich auch noch installieren.
Ich mag ja nicht.
Fuck.
Easy. Easy.
Fixed.
Easy as fuck.
Easy. Easy.
Easy.
So, da können wir das komische Webkit
Kompilierungszeug hier oben abbrechen.
Okay, also jetzt brauch ich ein Webkit
Account. Nein, kein Webkit Account.
Nein, ich habe kein Account.
Kann ich das,
kann ich das nicht im Browser irgendwie machen?
Äh, Garmin
Developer Account.
Wir machen wieder ein Fake.
Garmin Developer.
Okay.
Wo erstelle ich mir hier ein Account?
Account. Developer Forum.
Account.
Äh.
Ja, Developer Programm.
Okay, das ist super kompliziert
schon mal das Richtige zu finden.
Account.
Muss man das über die komische App,
muss man das wirklich hier drüber machen?
Okay, create a new Account.
Okay, also, ich habe die Terms,
ich habe die Terms gelesen und kriege
Max
Wupp
E-Mail-Adresse, okay.
10-Minute-Mail
Beste E-Mail-Adresse
überhaupt, die will ich haben.
Oh, man darf da nicht
copy-pasten, Mann, ist das nervig.
Z-Bock
Passwort.
Okay, ähm.
Mal kurz aufschreiben.
So.
Germany, create Account.
Ach, man muss doch nicht mal bestätigen.
Na, umso besser.
Man muss doch nicht mal bestätigen,
das ist gut.
Logged in as Max Wupp.
Next. Automatic Updates.
Automatic Downloads.
Automatic Updates, jawoll.
Ähm.
Watches, Bikes, Wearables, alles.
New Devices.
Devices are being downloaded.
Nice.
Okay.
Dann fetcht mal.
Yes.
Okay, das ist ja
gar nicht so schlecht gemacht.
Kriege ich erstmal 300 Emulatoren installiert?
Okay.
Oh, im Hintergrund geht da schon mal gut was ab.
Ehrlich gesagt, ich brauche gar nicht
die 1000 Sachen und Devices.
Aber gut, wir lassen ihn mal.
Wir lassen ihn mal kurz machen.
Ähm.
Also,
ehrlich gesagt,
ich glaube, das kann man auch gar nicht
abbrechen. Ich glaube, wir müssen den jetzt mal
kurz zwei Minuten in Ruhe lassen
und den Kram installieren.
Weiß ich nicht wirklich, was der gerade da
im Hintergrund treibt.
Also, wenn das in dem Tempo weiter geht,
dann sitzen wir morgen noch da.
Gucken, ob das überhaupt irgendwas macht
im Background.
Sieht jetzt für mich nämlich nicht so aus.
Öh.
Es ist noch am Downloaden und dann dauert es wahrscheinlich
nur wegen dem Download ein bisschen.
Das liegt am
Download, gehe ich mal von aus.
Das wird wahrscheinlich
unterschiedlich groß sein und der Download nicht so
schnell. Ich gehe davon aus, dass es alles dann
mehr oder weniger zeitgleich fertig
wird. Ich meine, es wäre
ja auch ganz sinnvoll, Preferences.
Wir machen einfach mal nur by Computer.
Aber dann bricht der trotzdem nicht ab.
Ich schau mal, ob ich das beschleunigen kann,
wenn ich quitte und nochmal starte.
Was?
Oh, ist das schlecht, Alter.
Was habe ich für eine E-Mail-Adresse?
Okay, zbog.
Okay, immerhin.
Guck mal, er downloadet jetzt tatsächlich
nur noch das, was ich haben will.
Okay, man musste...
Das wirkt aber ziemlich fragil,
was sie da gebaut haben.
Hast du geschaut, ob es eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail
gibt?
Mit sowas geben die sich das
gar nicht ab. Wer braucht schon
Bestätigungs-E-Mails?
Okay, das scheint ein bisschen schneller zu gehen.
So, wie geht's denn dann weiter?
So, als erstes
getten wir das Garmin SDK.
Complete First Time Setup Process.
Download Latest
Connect IQ SDK.
Download Complete.
Klick Yes.
Klick der SD... Close der
SDK Manager. Okay, wir können da schon mal
den nächsten Schritt machen.
In Visual Studio Code, go to
Extensions, Insta... Monkey
Sea, Alter, was ich mal...
Was wird schon wieder, dass ich hier alles
geben muss?
Könnten die... Können die nicht...
Also, könnten die nicht irgendeine
normale Programmiersprache
nehmen? JavaScript, Python, sonst was?
Warum muss es
Monkey Sea sein?
Nice FFmpeg HiRes GIF.
Okay, wir installieren die Monkey
Sea Extension. Gut, gut,
dass ich den Snapshot gemacht hab.
Moment, es gibt zwei Sachen.
Es gibt das.
Das ist das Offizielle
von Garmin und das hier ist
von Alexander Fedora.
Changelog ohne Datum ist
auch immer geil.
Hier, 2020.
Okay, das ist auf jeden Fall das Sinnigere.
Okay,
wir sind fertig.
Close. Das ist der Cousin
von... Der Cousin vor allem.
Btop ist
zu fancy.
Install Button.
Restart Visual Studio Code. Okay.
After Restart
Summon the Command Plate.
Verify
Installation and select
Installation.
Okay, Cousin
ist dumm, der macht das. Genau.
Verify Installation.
Generate Developer
Key? Was
mache ich gerade?
Downloads.
Garmin POC. Haben wir mal hier
einen Ordner? Irgendwie
Projects oder so?
Keine Ahnung. Open.
Ja.
Java.
Okay.
Java. Open JDK.
Was ist denn da
der Default mittlerweile?
Was installiert man denn, wenn man Java installieren will?
Open. Was ist das hier?
Open JDK 19.
21.
Was haben die da zusammen geschustert?
Ja, das frage ich mich
auch gerade.
Das frage ich mich auch.
Okay.
Nochmal Visual Studio Code starten.
Verify
Installation.
Okay. MonkeySee
Installation verified. Ganz toll.
Und jetzt?
Get the Connect IQ Mobile SDK.
Ne.
Das brauche ich nicht.
Und, und, und
jetzt?
Ich meine,
der Guide ist etwas
incomplete, oder?
Das SDK ist auch ein geiles
SDK. Es hat einfach keine
Beispiele oder sonst irgendwas dabei.
Okay.
Wir machen, wir gehen erstmal hier in
Projects und öffnen Visual Studio Code da.
Ja, ja.
Wir trusten. Oh, guck mal. Da ist mal ein
Developer Key. Den sollte ich, den sollte ich
vielleicht nicht leaken. Also machen wir hier
Projects 2.
So.
Okay. Visual Studio Code.
Ich truste.
Okay. Wie geht das jetzt?
Monkey. MonkeySee.
Clean Projects
Launch New Project.
Set Project
Name. Kackel.
Data Field Widget
Watch App.
Okay, Leute. Ich würde sagen, wir tun
erstmal so, weil ich glaube, da kommt man
am besten damit rein, als würden
wir eine Watch App
programmieren, weil ich hoffe, da ist so
eine Art Simulator oder sowas dabei.
Alternativ können wir auch einen
Monkey Barrel entwickeln, was auch immer
das ist. Vielleicht ein fancy Name für ein
Package. Watch Face.
Wir tun mal so, als wollen wir eine
Application. Ich will eigentlich
gar keine App, sondern ein Data Field bauen.
Mini. Na, immer beste,
neueste, geilste API.
Select the products to support.
Edge 840.
Project 2.
Ganz toll.
Nice.
Gibt es Hello World oder so?
Irgendwie.
Kackel App MC.
Uiuiui.
Es hat ein bisschen was von Dart, oder?
Findet ihr nicht auch?
Ein bisschen.
Es sieht.
Haben wir Autocomplete?
Ja. Hey.
Huiuiui.
Massive. Okay.
Gibt es sowas? Monkey.
Es muss ja irgendwie ein Run oder so.
Run.
Launch.
Configure Monkey Barrel.
What?
Build current project.
No device
available.
Ich habe doch Edge runtergeladen.
Äh.
Monkeys.
SDK Manager.
Da ist er.
Wie oft muss ich das noch machen?
Meine E-Mail Adresse. Sekunde.
Oh fuck.
Ähm.
Chat, hat jemand aufgepasst?
Z-Bock irgendwas?
Ah, da ist sie hier.
Z-Bock. Muss ich mir auch mal aufschreiben.
Wie oft muss ich das noch machen?
Okay, finish.
Hab ich doch hier. Guck mal.
Und was haben wir jetzt hier?
Manifests.
Was ist ein Data Field?
Sowas hier.
Eines dieser Kästchen hier unten.
Sollte ich den vielleicht im Hintergrund
einfach auch nochmal
die Uhren runterladen lassen.
Also eine zumindest.
Ja, Forerunner 255
hab ich.
Ich hab nen Watch. Ich hab nen App
Projekt erstellt.
Das ist glaube ich nicht,
dass sie einen Unterschied machen zwischen
Resources
Manifests.
Warum haben wir hier zweimal Kekkel?
Wir haben Projects Kekkel und
ich bin verwirrt. Warum
haben wir das hier doppelt offen?
Ich mach das mal kurz zu. Das ist komisch.
Monkey Jungle.
Boah ey, ich raste aus.
Können die nicht irgendwas
benutzen, was jeder versteht?
Da stand Watch UI.
Ich denke mal, das heißt halt einfach so.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
Use the following from
Visual Studio Code Command Palette
to edit build targets.
Set product
touch by computers
Ach einfach alles, bam.
Okay, easy.
Siehste?
Zack.
Jetzt haben wir alle Support.
Build current project für Edge.
Easy.
Jetzt ist nur
die Frage, wie man das in irgendeinem Simulator
starten kann.
Ich hab gesehen, dass
die sowas haben.
Launch complication.
Compilation?
Complication?
What?
Was wird hier gelauncht?
Okay, keine Ahnung.
Okay, build for device. Haben wir gemacht.
Edit application.
Edit export
project. Open.
Wieso heißt das Ding Monkey Sea und warum
brauchst du Java? Musst du Garmin fragen.
Okay, wir müssen mal
die Hilfeseite mal abchecken.
Okay.
Connect IQ basics.
Your first app.
Ist das Eclipse?
Okay.
Select project watch face.
Okay, select simple template.
Select minimum RP.
Run the
program. Okay, wie geht das?
Select
run without debugging.
Run?
Run without debugging.
Oh, es runnt.
Es runnt.
Easy.
Ey, komm mal an.
Der device emulator
emulated.
Oh, was ist nu?
Data fields, layout, invalid.
HDB connection.
Nee, nee, nee, bestimmt nicht.
Okay.
Ich hab nen Garmin Uhr und nen
Fahrradcomputer, ja.
Ich find die Dinger nice.
Activity data.
Sleep mode.
Okay, also wie hab ich das jetzt gemacht?
Run without debugging, also
Control F5.
Hat das Hot Reload?
Leute, das müssen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren.
Hat das so ne Art Hot Reload?
Ähm.
Wie kann ich denn das jetzt ausprobieren?
Resources,
Strings,
Appname, Kekke,
Kekke W heißt die App jetzt.
Nee.
Ah, ah.
Okay, das hat's nicht gecheckt.
Vielleicht muss ich erst
Build machen.
Das ist gar nicht so schlecht, Leute.
Das hätte ich mir jetzt schlimmer
vorgestellt.
Was ist denn der Knopf da unten?
Data playback.
Backlight.
Das ist doch gar nicht so kacke.
Das geht doch
voll klar.
Gut, dann kann ich tatsächlich nochmal
ein neues Projekt machen, nachdem ich jetzt weiß,
wie das funktioniert.
Ups, das hätte ich gar nicht schließen müssen.
New Project
Monkey C, und zwar
Ja, keine Ahnung, Data Field
nenne ich das einfach mal.
Ich will ein Data Field entwickeln.
Äh, Data Field
that extends the simple
Data Field Class.
A Data Field that extends
the Data Field Class.
Wir machen erstmal
Select Minimum Supported
API.
Ja, ich mein,
ich hab eh die neueste Version, so Edge.
Äh, und wohin?
Hier rein.
Ja.
Wollen wir das nochmal schließen.
Nach Data Field
Oh, what?
Hä?
Wart mal, ich bin verwirrt.
Hab ich das jetzt da rein erstellt, oder wie?
Ah ja.
Data Field eins nach oben.
Data Field
Und jetzt Visual Studio Code
hier drinnen öffnen.
Das da down save, zack.
Nice.
So, das sieht
jetzt deutlich, deutlich
weniger aus.
Schauen wir mal, Build
Current Project
Und jetzt
Ne, was? Wie war das? Run?
Run without debugging.
MonkeySea
Bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Hey, das Fundst?
Das, das Fundst
Data Fields Layout
Ja?
Also so würde das dann
Also eins davon wäre halt
nur mal ein Data Field und
realistisch, realistisch betrachtet
will ich eigentlich
4x4, weil ich ein breites
Ich will, ich will ein Data Field machen, was
ein zweier Data Field ausnutzt.
Wobei eher, eher
in der Größe würde ich sagen.
Das ist realistischer.
Ja, das funktioniert doch gar nicht mal
so mies.
Ganz gut, klar.
So, also mein Data Field muss gut aussehen
in dieser
in dieser Größe
weil mein Data Field
soll
hier unterhalb von der Map
angezeigt werden können.
Also Chat, was sagt ihr?
Ich finde, das ist gar nicht mal schlecht
wie die das bis jetzt gemacht haben.
Ich finde, das geht
echt klar, ja.
Das können wir noch ein bisschen kleiner machen hier.
So.
Ich finde das
Ich finde, das geht voll klar.
Ja.
So soll mein Data Field später aussehen.
Genau so.
Ein breites hier, wie das da.
Ja, wir haben auch schon schlimmeres
gesehen.
Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage, wie funktioniert
das? Also wir haben jetzt
ja bisher nur das ganze eingerichtet.
Wie programmiert
man den Kram? Ok, Data Field App
Extends Application Base.
Data Field View.
Jetzt schauen wir mal, wie gut
die Autocompletion ist.
Simple Data Field.
Ok, sie funktioniert
schon mal.
Noch
besser als das Rust Plugin noch vor
kurzer Zeit.
Ich habe natürlich absolut keine Ahnung von der API.
So, woher kommt
das überhaupt, dass es ein Label
gibt?
Woher weiß ich denn, dass es ein Label gibt?
Hat vielleicht
hat vielleicht das, vielleicht ist
das ein Base.
Gibt es sowas wie Base oder This oder so?
Vielleicht
kommt das ja vom Simple Data
Field.
Ok, Jump 2 gibt es schon
mal nicht.
Das heißt, wir müssen jetzt mal in die API
Docs reingucken. Zeig mal kurz, was
in Hessen so abgeht. Hochrechnung in
Hessen 1924.
Die CDU geht übelst ab.
Der Markt regelt immer noch bei 5%.
So, SDK.
API
Docs.
MonkeySea.
Containers.
Arrays in MonkeySea.
Ja, ok, ok, ok.
Coding
Conventions.
Das finde ich jetzt alles nicht so spannend.
Core Topics.
Glances, Layouts.
Field.
Was?
Ja, wie?
Was gucke ich denn da jetzt am besten?
API Docs?
Hier, Simple.
Simple Data Field. Da haben wir es doch.
Simple Data Field.
Was jetzt?
Ist einfach ein Browser aufgegangen bei mir.
Monks.
Einfach random.
Chat, wer von euch war das
wieder?
Wer hat gerade random
Explorer geöffnet?
Ja, Sauerei.
Ok.
Ah, hier, guck mal.
Simple Data Field that displays current heart rate.
Return Info.
Specified
Activity Info to display in the field
here. Function Compute.
Ah, ich
jetzt verstehe ich halbwegs, wie das
funktioniert. Das ist ein bisschen
wie, ja,
das ist, naja, ok.
Es ist ein bisschen
wie ein Custom
Windows Forms
Element.
So nach dem Motto onDraw und dann
da drin das machen. Und Compute ist
wahrscheinlich einfach der Text, der
zurückkommt.
Ähm, übrigens Format funktioniert
schon mal nicht richtig. Format.
No Formatter for MonkeySee.
Ja gut, das wundert mich
jetzt nicht wirklich. Ok.
0.0 Return. Also sprich
Info. Info.
Heart Rate.
Ach, das ist ja nice, ok.
Da sieht man alles, was es gibt.
Dann returnen wir das doch mal.
Current Heart Rate. Ich mein, die ist 0,
weil da ist sonst nix, aber ok.
So, dann schauen wir doch mal. Jetzt machen wir
Build.
Build Current Project und
Restart.
Wenn wir Glück haben, steht jetzt meine Heart Rate drinne.
Was ich aktuell mach? Ein Custom Data
Field für Garmin Devices bauen.
Ok, da gibt's wahrscheinlich einfach
keine Daten aktuell.
Ok, Label können wir machen.
Hier. Heart Rate.
Ja, lass wir's.
Ja, wobei ist eigentlich egal.
Die Keck V Rate ist das.
So, Build.
Wenn es fertig ist, einmal Shift
Ctrl F5.
Vielleicht kann man das in der Simulation einstellen.
Ja, muss ich mal gleich gucken.
Keck V Heart Rate. Simulation.
Activity Data.
Wow. Das macht einfach was.
Lab Timer.
Ok, wir haben die
Simulation gestartet anscheinend.
Na gut, das
generatet einfach random Werte.
Es soll mir ja recht
sein. Random Werte. Vollkommen ok.
Hast du ein Power Meter?
Nein. Da würde ich aber überlegen, wie ich
das am besten mache. Gibt's ja verschiedene Systeme.
Gibt's ja Pedale. Gibt es
ja Kurbeldinger und
komplette
so Sets.
Weil, aber ganz ehrlich.
Erstmal ordentlich
Fahrrad fahren. Üben wieder.
So, das ist schon mal nice.
Das gefällt mir schon mal.
So, jetzt
kann ich, jetzt können wir mal was ausprobieren.
Ok, also übrigens Leute.
Ihr könnt alles ignorieren.
Außer das da.
Also
das ist.
Man kann glaube ich die Data Field
hier drinnen nicht anpassen.
Kann das Layout ändern
und. Oh.
Jetzt ist es gecrashed. Das war zu viel auf einmal.
Jetzt haben wir es kaputt gemacht.
Oh, was kann man da noch alles
einstellen? Time Units,
Language, Connection Type.
Nein, gut.
Das ist jetzt nix.
Wetter, Position,
Sensors. Du kannst echt
ziemlich viel einstellen.
Eigentlich ganz cool.
So, wo war das mit Simulation?
Ja.
So, ok. Wir lassen
das einfach mal so. Das wird
ja ganz sinnig angezeigt.
Ok, also. Jetzt der
Test. Jetzt testen wir einfach mal ein bisschen was.
Also es. Kann man
den View auf die
Navigationsanzeige umschalten?
Running, Sailing.
Ja, das ist jetzt mir
eigentlich ziemlich egal.
Navigation Data. Aber
das wird keine Map Anzeigen
hier drinnen. Das Go. Nein.
Nein. Das ist Monkey See.
Warum auch immer.
Kann man nicht.
Dann lassen wir das mal so.
Ok, also. Jetzt.
Jetzt probieren wir das mal ein bisschen aus.
Also sagen wir mal.
Ich würde gerne.
Das ist richtig eklig. Wobei.
Ich muss sagen. Es macht einen ganz brauchbaren Eindruck.
Also was ich gerne machen würde ist.
In meinem Widget.
Anzeigen.
Wir stellen die Data Fields doch nochmal
um. Hier. Was hatten wir?
4a oder so?
Ne. 5a?
B?
Ich hatte doch sowas, wo das eine
groß ist. Ja.
Das da.
So. Das ist das
obere. Komm. Wir machen eins.
Also. Eine Sache.
Ich würde gerne. Ne. Ich muss das
mit Rand.
Ich muss es mit Rand anzeigen.
Two Fields. Ja.
Von der Idee her. Ich will das der Rand
oder zumindest irgendwas
angezeigt wird. Wenn.
Ich will die Zone anzeigen.
Von der Heart Rate.
Also sprich.
Das was bei Garmin
standardmäßig. Grau. Blau.
Grün. Oh.
Mein Timer ist abgelaufen.
Äh. Grau. Blau.
Grün. Orange. Und Rot ist.
Ja. Timer ist
gut. Und das. Und das will ich.
Das. Das. Irgendwie.
Mal anzeigen. So. Also. Der Typ ist ganz schön.
Ganz schön am strampeln mit 152
Puls. Oh. Noch
mehr. So. Wie kriege
ich denn das jetzt raus? Also. Wie kriege
ich. Wie kriege ich Heart Rate Zonen raus?
Zonen? Okay.
HR Zone. Man hat leider keine Hilfe
dafür. Das wäre natürlich zu easy.
Wie macht man denn eine Debug
Ausgabe?
Wie macht man eine
Debug
Ausgabe?
HR Zone Biking zum Beispiel.
So. Wir stellen
die Activity mal ein.
Activity Select.
Wir machen jetzt. Das ist ein Fahrradcomputer.
Wir machen.
Bike.
Oder Cycling
heißt das. Cycling.
Was genau ist egal hier.
So. Wie macht man hier eine
Konsolenausgabe? Console.
Nein. System. System.
System ist immer gut. System.
Right. Rightline.
Nein.
Output. Nein.
Console. Nein. Okay. Ich muss nachgucken.
Print. Print. Könnte natürlich
auch noch sein. Print.
Tatsächlich. Printeln.
Keck W.
Okay. Build.
Restart.
Debug
Console. Output.
Ach hier.
Da ist es. Da ist die
Ausgabe.
Nice. Der Carlson.
Okay. Das
funktioniert. Es sieht für mich so aus
als wird das einmal pro Sekunde
gecallt. Was im Endeffekt auch
heißt. Man sollte hier drinnen keine
Endlosschleife fabrizieren. Weil dann
kann man das Device zum Hängen bringen.
Vermute ich jetzt einfach mal.
Wollen wir das mal ausprobieren.
For. Each.
For.
Wie macht man hier eine Schleife?
Monkey C.
Loops. Monkey C.
Loop. Wie sieht denn da eine Loop aus?
Loop. While true. Ja.
Hier. Do. While.
While loop. Okay. Dann machen wir das wirklich so.
While.
True.
Falls das so geht.
While true.
Kekwe. Beste Output.
Build.
Hat funktioniert.
Ist schon mal richtig. Und jetzt. Okay.
Endlosschleife.
Jetzt wird es abkacken gleich.
Ja. Oh.
Wow.
Oh. Es ist gecrashed.
Crash. Oh.
Fuck. Jetzt ist es komplett dead.
Okay. Endlosschleifen
in Data Fields sind keine gute Idee.
Das habe ich jetzt
gelernt. Vielleicht. Generell sind so
Locking Sachen
auf Embedded System
meistens keine allzu gute
Idee. Das sind ja
meistens ein Main Thread
und vielleicht ein paar Background Sachen. Aber die haben
bestimmt nicht ein Thread
für
jedes Data Field. Das wäre
viel zu krass dafür.
Simulator starten.
Data Field.
Wir hatten 5A.
Okay.
Und jetzt müssen wir noch starten.
Activities. Ne.
Cycling.
Ich crashe es
jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Wo ging das jetzt nochmal?
Was?
Wo ging das jetzt nochmal
mit den
Activity Data. Genau.
Okay.
Excellent.
Okay. Also. Hard Raid.
Biking.
Das gebe ich
doch mal aus. Mal gucken was
der mir da jetzt anzeigt.
Ist es gecrashed?
Error.
Ja wie jetzt? Was jetzt?
Could not find Symbol.
Oder kann ich das
bloß nicht printen?
Okay. Das findest du nicht.
Findest du nicht.
War. Blub. Gleich. Geht sowas?
Cannot find Symbol. HR.
Zone. Sport. Running.
Ja. Ich würde aber gerne meine Herzfrequenz
Zone wissen. Weil anhand dessen kann ich dann
einen Balken drum
herum malen. Oder auch
nicht.
Api Level. Ja.
Das haben wir. Das sind wir.
Ach. Moment.
Das ist irgendein
Inam. Das ist nicht wirklich
der
die Zone. Sondern.
Okay. Hier. Get Hard Raid
Zone. Kann man
da drauf zugreifen? Ach so.
Moment.
Jetzt bin ich hochgradig
verwirrt. Wie funktioniert
das jetzt?
Get Hard Raid
Zone. So. Und wir können da
theoretisch für Bike. Sagen wir 2.
Und jetzt bilden
wir das ganze mal.
Cannot find Symbol. Get Hard on Time.
Äh.
Hä?
Warum gibts das nicht?
Wir haben doch eine Api Version die
viel viel neuer ist.
Wie. Wie das hier.
Moment. Vielleicht
meckert er auch. Wie ich das. Dass ich das
falsch aufrufe.
Oh. Dann weiß ich auch nicht. Haben die vielleicht
einen. Okay.
Das sollte aber gehen. Get Current Sport.
Ups.
Get Current Sport.
Äh. Das sollte ja schon
funktionieren. Hä?
Muss ich irgendwas. Muss ich irgendwas
importen vielleicht?
Irgendwas.
Module. Toybox User Profile.
Ah. Leute. Ich muss. Ich muss.
Ich muss irgendwas importieren.
Okay. Import.
Toybox
User
Profile. Aha.
Sister.
Cannot find Symbol.
Okay.
Info as Activity Info. Das ist.
Das ist ne Variable von dem.
Okay. Das hat.
Das hat funktioniert.
Ah.
Muss ich das vielleicht. So.
Okay. User was born in year.
Das ist. Das ist ein gutes. Gutes
Exempel. System out
Brindeln. Was?
Ah. Die. Die.
Die Docs sacken einfach.
Permission User Profile required
for Toybox.
Oh. Permission.
Edit Permissions.
User Profile.
Leute.
Ich rate das übrigens auch hier gerade nur ganz
hart alles. Nicht das es jetzt irgendwie so
wirkt als wüsste ich was ich mache.
Okay. Es hat funktioniert. Es hat
kompiliert.
Reload. Bin ich ja mal
gespannt.
User was born in 1980.
Nice. Profile.
Get current
Sport.
Kann man das jetzt so machen?
Get current Sport.
Error. Hä. Alter.
Das ist ja super
pepega. Ja. Gibt
es.
Es gibt ne API um.
Um.
Die. Ne das nicht. Es gibt
ne API um die.
Übersetzung anzuzeigen.
Zum Beispiel.
Also das weiß ich nicht ob das geht.
Eher nicht oder. Also.
Ne das geht nicht. Ich weiß warum das nicht
geht. Weil die. Die.
DI2 is read only.
Die senden nur Daten. Die können keine
empfangen. Jetzt muss ich sagen. Jetzt
bin ich ein bisschen planlos. Warum
er. Mein API Level 1 0.
Wir sind auf API 4 2. Das sollte er
nur wirklich mal.
Gar kein Problem sein.
Ich gehe davon aus dass ich nicht
alles. Ich gehe davon aus
dass ich nicht alles importiert
habe was ich importieren muss.
Guck mal. Man kann das auch einfach so
ausgeben. Cannot find
symbol. Das ist total weird
champ. Alter.
Das ist total weird champ.
Ok. Profile. Was kann man denn
hier alles machen im Profile.
Ich sage mal. Leute. Kann das
sein dass das überhaupt nicht.
Kontextsensitiv
ist. Das es einfach
immer alles anzeigt.
Und deswegen
Cannot find symbol. Das zeigt.
Ok. Die Autocompletion ist kacke.
Die
Autocompletion ist dumm. Die zeigt
einfach immer das gleiche an.
Für alles.
Ja das ist dumm. Ok. Hier.
User Profiles.
Du hast ja die Zeile schon.
Was soll ich hier gucken.
Profile Activity Class.
Aber die haben doch hier auch drinnen
stehen.
Das ist der Typ den das
zurück liefert. Oder?
Ok. Get Current.
Hier.
Moment. Was?
Ok. Das ergibt ja gar keinen.
Ich meine Profile. Get Profile check ich
noch. Aber Profile
Get Current Sport. What?
Ach da ist sogar. Guck mal. Da ist sogar
ein Beispiel. Man ruft
das auf dem User Profile
Objekt auf.
Ha?
Ok. HR
Sport Bike. Ok.
Das ist sehr sehr
merkwürdig. Die Logik dahinter.
Aber es funktioniert. Ok.
Herzfrequenz. Zone. Anzeigen
in der Konsole. Auf gehts.
Ja. Kunst.
He. Ok.
Alter. Der wills aber wissen.
Herzfrequenz.
Detke würde ich sagen.
Aber gut. Das ist ja nur zum testen.
Ok.
Es ist bisschen weird. Man muss sich dran gewöhnen.
Ist bisschen weird. Aber
an sich nicht verkehrt.
Also. Heißt im Endeffekt
auch. Das heißt. Gut.
Heißt. Ok. Guck mal. Sag mal.
Zone. Beim
Fahrradfahren. Herz. Also
Herzfrequenz Zone beim Fahrradfahren.
Jetzt ist die Frage. Wie kann ich
anhand der Zone hier was rein
malen. Draw.
Draw Bitmap.
Draw Rectangle.
Draw Rectangle. Das klingt doch gut.
Braucht man überhaupt?
Semicolons.
Ok. Draw Rectangle.
Von oben links.
100 Pixel.
Weiß auch immer ob das Pixel sind. Ich weiß nicht.
Wahrscheinlich ist das übrigens wieder
das erfindet er das jetzt nicht.
Ja. Error. Undefined.
Was?
Achso.
Cannot find Symbol. Draw Rectangle. Ja gut.
Garmin.
Was das für eine Programmiersprache
ist. Das
ist Monkey
Sea. Weil Garmin der Meinung ist
Monkey Sea.
Frag nicht.
DC
Graphics. Haben wir ein Beispiel
dafür vielleicht?
Using Graphics.
Moment. Using. Import.
Ja was denn jetzt?
Ok. Ist das jetzt Using oder ist das
Monkey Sea
Using Import.
Ich sag mal
Import. Ok.
Could not draw. Function on
Update.
Das muss ich aber doch bestimmt nicht im Data
Field machen. Mach ich das in der App?
Wie male ich
ein
Ja. Geht.
Wie male ich ein Rectangle.
Fatal.
Draw hello world
on the center of the screen. Ok.
Using Toybox
Graphics. DC.
Das muss man on update machen.
Also nicht hier rein, sondern
ich weiß nicht ob es hier rein muss.
On update.
Wahrscheinlich nicht.
And build successfully.
Wait a minute. Funktioniert das jetzt?
Nicht wirklich.
Wo muss ich denn on update überhaupt reinpacken?
Und was ich sehr verwirrend
finde. Warum ist es using
oder import? Geht da
vielleicht beides?
Ja es geht beides. Ok. Das ist
das ist wir. Wenn es das gleiche
Keyword gibt. Sehr gute Idee.
Ja.
Poolcam App
für die Uhr.
Also das funktioniert so schon mal
nicht. Garmin on update
und show on update.
Moment. Das ist ja auch
verkehrt.
Das muss ich bestimmt hier drinnen machen.
Ja. Muss bestimmt hier rein.
Build successfully.
Ok.
Garmin data field
on update.
Wir können ja mal testen ob das
überhaupt. Hier.
On update.
On. On.
Update.
The system will call on update method.
From view when a data field is displayed by
because compute and update are asynchronous.
There is no guarantee that compute will be called before
on update.
Ok. Man heißt man
weiß nicht was zuerst geladen wird.
Vielleicht wird das überschrieben.
Und was passiert hier überhaupt?
View. Pint.
Trouble. By ID.
Uh.
Ich würde vorschlagen wir machen das mal anders.
Wir löschen das hier wieder.
Wir gucken erstmal ob das
überhaupt aufgerufen wird.
Wir gucken mal
ob das überhaupt aufgerufen wird.
On update.
Dann sagen wir jetzt einfach
System. Printline.
Update.
Ok. So. Build.
Build successfully.
Restart. Output.
Kann man das Leute. Visual Studio Kenner.
Kann man das irgendwie so splitten.
Dass ich beides mir anzeigen lassen kann.
Den
Bild Output und die
Konsole.
Wie splitte ich denn das gescheit?
Habt ihr da eine Ahnung von wie das funzt?
Ups. Oh je.
Hab ich zugemacht.
Ok. On update. On update wird schon mal
nicht aufgerufen. On update juckt das
nicht. Es wird
aufgerufen.
Current heart rate. Ok. Vielleicht ist
watch UI simple data field
nicht das richtige. Sondern ich muss
data field in inherit
error.
So schon mal nicht. Ok.
Guck mal. Man muss data field
Ich copy paste mir mal
kurz die Beispiel App hier.
Äh.
Moment. Jetzt geht natürlich
main. Jetzt geht natürlich die main App nicht.
Wie hieß das vorher?
Data field view.
Und jetzt heißt es.
Ah. Jetzt heißt
es. Moment. Wie heißt das? My HR
field. Ok.
Build.
Undefined symbol. Main layout.
Main
layout. Ist undefined.
Sehr nice
example. Kann ich das einfach
rauskommentieren?
Gucken ob es jetzt läuft.
Shit man.
Oh Gott.
Abartig.
Das funzt so schon mal nicht richtig.
Ok. Kann ich wenigstens alte
wieder bilden? Was?
Undefined symbol detected?
Achso.
Ja.
Update.
Was über view?
Oder rechts oben am
Tabrand?
Achso. Das Terminal.
So. Also simple
simple on update
simple data field.
Ich
Ich glaube
das
funktioniert mit einem simple data
field nicht.
Wobei direct known
subclasses. Das muss
also auch in dem simple
data field
funktionieren.
Ja.
Keine Ahnung.
Ähm.
Mir fällt jetzt gar nichts anderes
ein als
nochmal eine neue App zu
erstellen.
Ah ne. Das geht ja nur mit code.
Und einfach data field auszuwählen.
New project.
Ah.
Five head.
Data field
complex data field.
Und nehmen wir wieder die
aktuelle API.
Edge. Ok.
Und das ganze kommt
hier rein.
Project 2. Gut.
Das kann sich mal wieder verpissen.
So.
Sources.
Five head view. On layout.
Compute. On update.
Hier haben wir jetzt ne on update.
Ja. Also anscheinend
muss man das wirklich im
muss das wirklich in normales data field.
Aber das ist doof, dass das nicht mit nem
mit nem simple
data field geht. Gut.
Wie auch immer. Bild.
Äh.
Habe ich da irgendwo ausversehen ne 5 grad
reingepastet oder so?
What?
Oh nein.
Der unterstützt five head nicht.
Die Dinger dürfen nicht mit 5.
Die dürfen keine Zahlen drin haben.
Ok.
Ähm.
Five head heißt es dann jetzt halt.
Hehehe.
Oh Mann.
Ok. Bild.
Bild.
Ok. Jetzt hat es funktioniert.
Run.
In dem Repo. Hat der nen simple data field in seinem Repo?
Das on update
funktioniert?
Was für ein Window Manager? Das ist i3. Ok.
Das funktioniert schon mal. Also.
On update.
Das haben wir vorhin nicht gemacht.
Daran lag es wahrscheinlich.
Wir haben nicht das parent
Wir haben nicht das parent on update
gecallt. Deswegen ist nix
passiert. Ok. Wir drawen
jetzt eine Rectangle.
Rect.
Rectangle wird jetzt gedrawt.
Und zwar sagen wir
jetzt mal. Hier.
Wie man das jetzt gescheit macht. Draw.
Ne. Wie geht das?
DC. Draw.
Rectangle.
Ähm. Moment.
Leute.
Woher weiß der überhaupt? Was ist denn
Value?
View find drawable by
ID. Value. What?
Kann ich sowas?
Bildet das jetzt?
Ok.
Immerhin. Es bildet. Reload.
Mal gucken ob wir jetzt n Rectangle in irgendeine
Art. Ich muss ja die Color noch irgendwie
setzen. Und? Rectangle?
Nein. Kein Rectangle
da. Sowas wie DC.
Set Color. Ok.
Oh meine Güte ey. Das ist nicht so
einfach. Graphics.
Da war doch eben irgendwo ein Beispiel.
Ja.
DC. Set Color. Blue
Black. Ah.
Fill Rectangle dann.
Ok. Dann lassen wir die ganzen
Shit mal weg und machen so wie im Beispiel.
Bild. Ok.
Reload. Moment. Der fängt
schon bei 100 an. Ähm.
Wir wollen auch bei 0 anfangen. Bei 0
und dann. Ja aber das scheint
nicht zu funktionieren. Ah.
Eine
Blur Rectangle.
Nice.
Warum. Warum ist mein.
Warum wird das jetzt
angezeigt?
Ok. Ok.
Nice. Nice. Nice. Nice.
Das ist doch schon mal. Das ist doch schon mal nicht schlecht.
So. Und
funzt.
Funzt das denn auch mit
dem
Simple Data Field?
Source? Data Field?
Oh mein. Ne. Moment.
Es wurde ja mit dem Simple Data Field
nie das Update aufgerufen. Ne. Funktioniert
nicht.
Wie wirbst du dich bei Garmin? Ja klar. Ganz bestimmt.
Warum das Rectangle nicht quadratisch
ist. Das ist äh.
Wahrscheinlich. Weil
das schlicht und ergreifend abgeschnitten ist.
Weil das nicht so weit. Weil das keine 100
Pixel hat. Guck mal.
Probieren wir das mal aus. Machen wir mal 20x20.
Reloaden.
Ups. Run.
Äh. Ok.
Guck. Jetzt ist es quadratisch.
Das wurde einfach geklippt unten.
Was ist das für eine Sprache? Das ist Monkey
Sea. Das ist irgendwas von.
Irgendwas eigenes von Garmin.
Ok. Also mal zurück
zu der eigentlichen Sache die ich ausprobieren
wollte.
Wir wissen jetzt wie wir farbige
farbige
Rechtecke malen. Ok.
Also. Dann.
Warte mal. Ich mach nochmal ein neues Visual Studio
Code auf. Und öffne hier mal
das Data Field. Da können wir uns das nämlich
abgucken. Hier.
Heart Rate.
Heart Rate Zone.
Ok. Das gibt nen Array.
Das muss man. Vorher muss man irgendwie
Using User Profile oder irgendwas.
User Profile.
Nein. Das ist. Das ist irgendein.
Unter der Haube macht der Java
Zeug. Ich hab keine Ahnung was das
eigentlich wirklich ist.
Five Head Background.
Find ich nen guter Name. Five Head Background.
Ok.
So. Jetzt haben wir die Heart Rate.
Und wie haben die nochmal hier jetzt was.
Muss ich grad mal checken.
Oh ne. Ich kann nicht mal weiter zurück.
No.
Wie haben die das mit Find Draw. Oh nein.
Hab ich. Hab ich.
Ach. Weil ich es geschlossen
hab. Ah. Ist ja doof.
Wie haben die das gemacht. Find Draw.
Und. Und dann irgendwie.
So. Weil. Weil.
Von der Idee her. Ich würd jetzt ja gerne.
Ich würd jetzt ja gerne nochmal nen Text malen.
So. Das haben die doch irgendwie gemacht.
Irgendwie View. Find.
Drawable. By ID.
Value. Oder. Oder sowas.
In der Richtung.
Ich bin mir da nicht mehr sicher. Irgendwie so lief das doch.
Ne.
Achso. Permission. Permission.
User Profile.
Ah ja.
Nein.
Build Project.
Successful. Nice.
Okay. View.
Find Drawable.
Da muss ich mir die
Docs angucken. Find Drawable. By ID.
Ja.
Find Drawable. By ID. Time Label.
Set Text.
Nennen wir es mal. Eval. Set Text.
Cackle.
Okay. So. Mal gucken ob das jetzt funzt.
Error.
Set Text. Okay.
Nice. GG Eats.
Okay. Ich copy paste mir das mal.
Glaub das besser funktioniert.
Ah ne. Timestring.
Set Text. Okay. Das Example
Sucked. Wie sahen das aus?
Okay. Chat.
Wir gucken jetzt einfach mal kurz bei mir ins Stream.
Ins Watt.
Da hat mans ja. Da hat mans
ja eben gesehen.
Ja. Ja. Da wars doch.
Was hab ich hier für ein Projekt offen?
Date is a
simple data field.
Hier. Da wars doch. Hier.
Find Drawable.
Hier. On Update.
Ah.
Value.
Das hab ich doch. S Text. Aha.
Da war das doch
gar nicht so. S.
Das ist ein Cast oder
sowas.
Okay. Bisschen weird champ ist das schon.
Aber jetzt bildet das.
Jetzt muss ich. Ich musste doch noch irgendwas
machen.
Jetzt muss ich noch sagen. View.
View on Update
DC.
View on
Update DC.
Warum man nicht sein Smartphone
als Fahrradcomputer nimmt.
Die offensichtlichste Sache ist
Laufzeit.
Und Features.
Aber
Laufzeit dürfte wahrscheinlich so das Argument
sein was jedem einleuchtet.
Mach mal 3 Stunden
Navigation mit ordentlicher Bildung.
Bildhelligkeit beim Smartphone.
Aha.
Okay. Das ist schon mal dumm.
Das ist schon mal richtig dumm.
Wenn ich
nicht
nicht zeichnen
muss ich das
Moment. Muss ich das vielleicht nacheinander machen?
Muss ich zuerst das updaten
und dann hinten dran die
Rectangle malen.
Nur mal so.
Das es auf die Reihenfolge ankommt.
Kann ja sein.
Ah. Nice.
Was warnt er mich denn hier?
Ach ist not used.
Bin doch egal.
System.
Brindeln.
Zone.
So. Wie kriege ich das jetzt hin?
Also mein Ziel ist.
Das meine Hardrate da steht.
Das jetzt nur zum testen.
Und hier unten ein Rectangle gemalt wird.
Mit
der passenden Farbe.
Eigentlich. Eigentlich will ich
gar kein Rectangle.
Ich will eigentlich einmal drum herum
sowas malen.
Aber ich meine wir können auch erstmal das
hier oben
einfärben dann.
Was ist das für ein Emulator.
Das was beim Garmin SDK dabei ist.
Also. Heißt im Endeffekt auch.
If.
Und wie sieht denn das.
Mal reloaden.
Chat. Wie funzt denn das jetzt nochmal?
Konnte man das hier irgendwie splitten?
Oder so. Das ging doch. Man konnte doch irgendwie
sagen.
Man konnte doch irgendwie
sagen das man.
Das ist Panel.
Ich will nämlich beides
anzeigen. Das ist Monkey
Sea. Das ist so ein.
So ein Garmin Ding.
Oh. Graphics. Color. Black.
Ne Moment.
Ist das.
Set Color. Warum sind
das zwei? Vordergrund
und Hintergrund? Oder.
Oder wie?
Hä?
Set Color. Ah ja.
Foreground. Background. Ok.
Foreground. Background.
White.
Color. White.
Auf Garmin. Reloade.
Ok. Das funktioniert.
Wobei ich.
Das hier ja gar nicht brauche.
Das ist schon durchaus ok gewesen.
Background Color gibt's
ja. Background Color
gibt's ja in dem Fall nicht. Wie machen die das
hier? Value.
Value.
Value. Set Color.
Black. Ok. Also sagen wir hier.
So. Dass der Text wenigstens
auch gescheit aussieht.
Und jetzt können wir sagen. If.
Sollen wir mal ausprobieren.
Ja. Äh. Sieht.
Sieht auch nicht besser aus. Der Text sieht
ziemlich. Ziemlich pepega broken aus.
Hm.
Moment. Das da oben ist ja nur das
Label oder?
Da steht ja gar nicht
Keckel. Da steht My Value.
Das ist ja auch verkehrt hier. Oder?
Value. Set Text.
Warum halten
der nix? Warum? Hä?
Ich mach das doch genauso
wie die das machen.
Ahmet. Geh mir nicht auf den Keks.
Warum sagt. Warum
setzt der denn das Value nicht?
Set Color.
Muss man das jetzt verstehen?
Set Text.
Seht ihr irgendwie den.
Ach. Guck mal hier.
Find Trouble by ID as Text.
Set Color. Aha. Ok.
Das ist ja so.
Ok. Das ist ja wirklich übelst.
Moment.
Ach. Background. Muss man das noch?
Alter.
Das muss mal einer checken.
Ok. Was?
Background?
Was haben sie denn sich da
ausgedacht?
Ich steig da auch nicht so wirklich durch.
So. Das ist ja im Prinzip das Kopieren.
Set Background Color.
Hehe.
Get Background Color.
So.
Reload.
Ob das jetzt irgendwas
gebracht hat?
Ha?
Nö.
Ok. Wir machen.
Color. Color. Color. Color.
Color Blue.
Nicht Blau. Blue.
Moment. Ob der irgendwas anzeigen kann?
Ah.
Background.
Ja. Deswegen ist es dumm.
Sowas mit Strings zu machen.
Oh. Error. Was?
No Viable Alternative.
Was?
Was ist denn jetzt schon wieder das Problem, Mann?
Aber.
Ich habe es doch genau so gemacht. View.
Find Trouble as Text. Set Color.
Ach. Hier. Da fehlt ein.
Error. Alter.
Schnell ab, Mann.
Ok. Es ist Graphics. Color.
Build successful.
Nice. So. Brake.
Einfach funktionieren.
Ok.
Jetzt macht es gar nichts mehr.
Geil. Top.
Moment. Der Emulator ist abgekackt.
Ach.
Jetzt geht es auf einmal.
Ok. Leute. Ich check nichts.
Aber solange es funktioniert,
soll mir das Recht sein.
Ok.
Also. Dann.
If.
Jetzt können wir endlich mal ein bisschen Logik bauen.
Also. If.
Macht man überhaupt so ein If
in dieser komischen Sprache?
Monkey C. If.
Language Reference.
If.
Ok. Ja. Macht man.
Also. If.
Sound.
K.
Orph Array.
Syntax ist so was hier in der Richtung.
Also.
So. Moment.
Wie hat man die Herzfrequenz ausgelesen?
Info. Current Heartrate.
Ok. Heartrate.
Wenn.
Current Heartrate.
Kleiner gleich.
Sagt, wenn ich Mist mache.
Eh. Kleiner gleich.
Die erste Zahl ist.
Dann gibt kein Pattern Matching.
Ja, das wird mich auch nicht.
Achso.
Also wenn das die erste Zahl ist, dann will ich Color.
Machen wir einfach mal so.
Color gleich.
Die Default Color ist einfach Graphics Color Gray.
Oder Gray.
Wie schreiben die das?
Gray.
Oh Leute, was habe ich da gesehen?
Triggert.
Manche bestimmt schon.
Gray.
DK Gray?
LT Gray.
Light Dark Gray vielleicht?
Machen wir Light Gray.
Dark Gray.
Okay, das ist Default.
Das brauchen wir nicht, weil es Default mäßig Gray ist.
Alles klar.
Also, wenn das kleiner ist, als Heartrate Zone 2, dann wird Color Blue.
Ja.
So.
Else is.
If.
Wenn Heartrate kleiner als Zone 2, dann Green.
Und wenn Heartrate kleiner gleich Zone 3, dann Color Orange.
So, das reicht jetzt erstmal zum Ausdruck.
Und ansonsten Else.
Ah, ne.
Muss ich schon noch mit dem 11 Else machen, weil den Default Fall habe ich hier oben schon.
Äh, Moment.
Ne.
Äh, ne.
Else.
Schon okay.
Else Rot.
So.
Color Red.
Und dann muss ich hier oben noch was einbauen.
Das da.
Ähm.
0.
Gray.
Okay.
So.
Äh, Zone 4 gibt es.
Moment.
Achso, es gibt ja noch mehr.
Warte mal.
Moment.
Es gibt.
Ach, es gibt da noch 5?
Ich dachte Garmin hat bloß.
1.
Achso, 5, ja.
Ja, na gut, passt doch.
Danach gibt es, danach gibt, danach gibt es, Else, das ist der Else-Zweig, ja, das passt doch.
Okay, Color.
Dann hier.
Hier die Color und für die, und für die Rectangle die Color.
Bild.
Error.
Was ist jetzt schon wieder das Problem?
Info.
Äh, was habe ich verkehrt gemacht?
Moment.
Ah, äh, Activity Info.
Das muss ich importieren.
Oder?
Tollbox Activity, okay.
Ah.
Ne, ist doch.
Ist doch.
Was ist das Problem?
Activity.
Muss ich sagen, Activity Info?
Muss ich das so machen?
Ach man.
Garmin.
SDK.
Ah, okay.
Aha.
Activity Get Activity Info ist es in dem Fall.
Da musst du erst mal drauf kommen.
Okay, hat funktioniert.
Was?
Äh, was?
Was genau ist jetzt das Problem?
Okay, wir müssen eine Runde Printline Debugging machen.
System.
Print.
Hardrate.
Und System Print Zone.
Oh, Mann, Alter.
Vielleicht kann Hardrate nicht ausgelesen werden.
Das könnte natürlich sein.
Und dass er deswegen.
Dass er Permissions für Activities braucht.
Könnte das sein?
Dass er keine, dass er keine Permissions hat für Activities?
Das ist null.
Die Hardrate ist null.
Okay.
Permissions.
Äh, Sensor vielleicht?
Lass uns mal gucken.
Was hat das Ding hier für Permissions?
Permissions.
Nee, das hat auch nur.
Es nun Merrick.
Or duration or String.
Okay, Activity Info funktioniert schon mal nicht.
Ach so, vielleicht ist die Hardrate Simulation nicht an.
Ja, das wird's.
Wahrscheinlich sein Simulation.
Wo war das jetzt?
Ah, das war das Problem.
Das war nicht an.
Okay, das müssen wir aber auf jeden Fall bedenken.
Es müssen wir auf jeden Fall bedenken, was das Null sein kann.
Weil dann.
Funktioniert es nicht.
Wo stand hier was?
Hardrate works fine steht da.
First to get.
You want to check that?
First to check.
Ähm, aber die Farbe stimmt nicht.
Oh, bei oder vielleicht stimmt die Farbe ja doch.
Ah, jetzt.
Okay, wir müssen das erst mal checken, ob das Null ist.
If.
Ganz einfach.
HR Null.
Ich hoffe, das macht man so.
Then return.
Nein.
Das macht man nicht so.
Doch, das macht man so.
Zeile 77.
Was denn?
Okay, System.
Print.
Print line.
Die Hardrate.
Dass ich weiß, was abgeht.
Und jetzt sagen wir run without debugging.
Ja, 82.
Was ist da?
Ah, Moment, ich habe doppelt if hier stehen.
Moment, wait a minute.
Ja.
Aber es ergibt trotzdem keinen Sinn, warum das.
Ja doch, 123 ist blue.
Ne, Moment.
123.
Ist.
124.
Ist unterhalb von Zone.
Von Zone 1.
Okay, da müsste es, dann müsste es Cray sein.
Okay, das war.
Das war der Bug.
Okay, alles gut.
Restart.
So, jetzt.
Ja, ja.
So, der Typ, der muss mal ein bisschen, ein bisschen schaffen hier.
Ein bisschen anstrengen.
Funktioniert.
So, der müsste jetzt mal ein bisschen höhere Herzfrequenz bekommen.
Das ist jetzt.
153 wird er so schnell nicht kriegen.
Zumindest.
Zum testen müsste der mal ein bisschen höhere Herzfrequenz bekommen, der Dude.
Was zum?
Bin ich hier gelandet?
Ich wollte wupp wupp wieder anmachen.
Ah, guck mal.
131.
Jetzt wird es, jetzt wird es blau.
Okay, sehr schön.
Das funktioniert ja.
Das ist im Prinzip genau das, was ich haben will.
Also, ich will jetzt nicht wirklich die Zahlen hier anzeigen.
Aber ich will eine Rectangle malen.
Anhand der jeweiligen Herzfrequenz.
Ne.
Ne, das ist gut.
Jetzt hat er 151.
Moment, 151 ist immer noch hier drunter.
Der hat ziemlich krasse Herzfrequenzzonen.
Der Demo-Typ.
Oh.
Okay, jetzt können wir mal die Rectangle an irgendeiner sinnvollen Stelle positionieren.
Ich würde, ich würde ja gerne,
ehrlich gesagt,
einfach nur einen Streifen malen.
Ich würde ja am liebsten
einen Streifen.
Ich will ja nicht einfach da oben sowas.
Einen Streifen, ja.
Einen Streifen sollte ja reichen.
Also mal Fill Rectangle.
Am besten unten.
Unten oder oben.
Oben ist halt am einfachsten.
Ach guck mal, jetzt wirds grün.
Jetzt wirds grün.
Es funktioniert alles.
Okay, nice. Das finde ich cool.
Also am besten wäre natürlich, wenn er
unten, oben, links, rechts.
Keine Ahnung, wo da das beste ist.
Wir machen es oben.
Oben dürfte es am einfachsten sein.
Ein grüner Strich.
Okay, was ist was?
Fill Rectangle ist
Referenz von
Ja.
Breite, Höhe.
Okay, also
Höhe, sagen wir mal 4 Pixel.
Breite.
Es wäre cool, wenn man irgendwie relative Einheiten
machen könnte, aber kann man anscheinend nicht.
Okay, 4 Pixel, Höhe
und irgendwie, keine Ahnung, 2000
Pixel wide. Das sollte glaube ich
reichen. Das wird dann zwar abgeschnitten, aber
das macht ja nichts. Das will ich ja.
Ja. Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Jetzt wird oben
in dem jeweiligen Data Field
eine Linie angezeigt,
die die
Herzfrequenz
quasi
symbolisiert.
Ich brauche ja gar kein
Label, wo das angezeigt
wird.
Je nachdem, wenn sich das
ändert. Machen wir nochmal
eine andere Herzfrequenz. Ja genau, 133.
Dann wird das
blau oder grau oder sonst was.
Das finde ich eigentlich gar nicht so
schlecht, weil ich will ja ein paar, ich will ja
ein bisschen mehr Werte anzeigen können
und die Pulsfrequenz, die brauche ich
nicht unbedingt direkt
als Zahl. Die reicht eigentlich
als Strich. Und jetzt
müssen wir das irgendwie Layout mäßig
so machen, dass ich drei
da müssen wir uns Layouts
angucken, dass ich quasi das hier dreifach
gleichmäßig unter
unterteilt bekomme.
Da müssen wir mal
in den Guide gucken.
Layout
Set Layout
Main Layout
Was passiert
hier?
On Layout
Compute
Set Layout
Top Left Layout
Top Right
Ah, Moment.
Ne, das ist nicht mein Layout.
Das ist, ich kann
mein, ich kann das anpassen
je nachdem, was der Typ
was der User für Layouts ausgewählt
hat. Ey, das sind die
Default Garmin Farben.
So.
Mit der Devicebreite, ja, aber da muss ich das selbst
ausrechnen. Das ist doch blöd.
Es wäre doch viel besser, wenn es was Fertiges gibt.
Aktuell
interessiert sich
das ist jetzt erstmal
nicht so, nicht so wild.
Ich will
ein Layout haben, innerhalb
von meinem Data Field.
Ich will, ich will quasi so eine Art Grid
haben.
Falls es sowas gibt.
Gibt es ein Grid?
Max, wie war das mit den Demo?
Wo war das Demo Repo?
Das geht bestimmt.
Das geht bestimmt. Man muss nur wissen,
nach was man sucht. Also Layout
ist auf jeden Fall schonmal falsch. Irgendwas
mit Box vielleicht?
Bauen Ding Box.
Check Box Menü.
Data Field.
Warte hier. On Update
Clear Clip.
Was auch immer.
Was da geklippt wird.
Ey, der Typ hat ja richtig krass viele, viele
Beispiele. Aber wie man
wie man da irgendwelche
Trouble, wie man da irgendwelche Layouts macht.
Auch nicht, ne?
Ich mein natürlich kann ich das, kann ich das selbst
irgendwie ausrechnen. So
Devicebreite durch 3
oder sowas. Okay.
Wie kriege ich, wie kriege ich die Breite
von dem Device
raus?
Get Text? Get Width?
Okay. Ja.
DC Get Width.
Gucken wir uns das mal an.
DC. Schauen
wir mal.
Was das, was das sagt.
Was das ausgibt.
Achso, das da.
246.
So, also da könnte ich
natürlich schon sagen.
With.
Man könnte das quasi durch 3 teilen,
wenn ich 3 Sachen anzeigen möchte.
Ja und dann, dann hat man
irgendwie Cell Width oder sowas.
Und dann habe ich
für, dann weiß ich
wo die Begrenzung ist.
Das erste ist
0 bis.
Das nächste ist
ja, das plus das.
Und beim nächsten ist Schluss bei
Breite. Breite minus Width.
Ja, das könnte man machen. Da könnte man
quasi anhand dessen ausrechnen,
wo man was hinmalen
möchte. Das können wir jetzt ja mal
kurz ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert.
Also.
Ja, das
funktioniert aber so schon mal nicht.
Weil der hier irgendwelche festen
Labels setzt.
Das ist halt, zack.
Ne, wo hier?
Wo setzt, wo setzt
der überhaupt hier die Sache mit dem? Ach hier
Value. View Value.
Wo hat er das
überhaupt her?
Kann es sein, dass es schlicht und ergreifend
jedes Data Field
sowas bekommt?
Ohne, dass man das
selbst einfügen muss? Wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich hat jedes Data Field
einmal Label und einmal
Text. Das
doofe ist, das kann ich jetzt ja gar nicht verwenden.
Wobei doch, guck mal.
Ich kann, aber
ich brauche ja mehrere Values. Das funktioniert
schon mal nicht. Ich glaube, ich muss das
komplett selbst malen.
Keine Chance. Also eigentlich
bringt mir das hier gar nichts.
Das Zeug. Das kann ich
theoretisch komplett
Cu
M Value. Benutzt das doch
irgendwo was? Kann man hier
irgendwas machen? Was gibt
es denn? Moment, guck mal. Data Field
Data Field
Es geht ja aktuell ums
Display. Was hat denn das für
Methoden?
Dude Master, danke schön für den Sub.
Compute Create Field
Aha.
Create a
New Custom Fit Field.
What?
Ok.
Ich probiere das jetzt einfach mal aus.
Data Field
Create Field
Name
Ah, hier kann ich
Ok. Name. Bloop.
Field ID. Ja.
Keine Ahnung. 2.
Type. Man weiß es nicht.
Create Field
Unique Field Identifier.
Ok. Komm. 69.
Der ist bestimmt noch frei. Type.
Data Type.
Wir machen mal Data Type String.
Data Type String und
Options. Gibt es noch was? Count.
Message Type.
Das ist Optional.
Optional kommt weg. Bam.
Error.
No Viable Alternative
Add Input Data Field
Create. Ok.
Es ist Optional, aber ich muss trotzdem
irgendwas eingeben.
Also
Äh.
0?
Wenn es Optional ist.
1? Hä?
Alter.
Das wird zu Six Head, Alter.
Der Kram. Garmin.
Haben wir da nicht irgendwie ein Beispiel?
Hat der Typ in GitHub, hier in diesem
GitHub Repo. Ich bin
keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
What the f...
Permission Fit Contributor?
Ich bin mir
nicht sicher, ob das wirklich das ist, was ich
haben will. Moment.
Das ist ein Data Field für Garmin Connect.
Das ist
was ganz anderes.
Moment. Das ist für die Zusammenarbeit
mit der Mobile App.
Ne. Das ist gar nicht das, was ich haben will.
Ok. Das ist
falsch. Also
die Docs sind auch nicht so
Aussage
kräftig.
Create a new Fit Field.
Field records
custom fit data
to a fit file on a device
Ok. Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht
das, was ich haben will. Das ist
pp egal.
Nein, nein, nein. Das brauchen wir nicht. Ok. Dann
zurück zum eigentlichen Plan.
Das da kommt alles weg.
So.
Und im Endeffekt
Was ist denn hier? Warum ist
das rot?
Weil der das nicht gecheckt hat.
So.
Heißt im Endeffekt
aber auch
Ich muss das wirklich
Ich muss das wirklich selbst berechnen.
Das heißt ich kann mir das hier
komplett sparen und muss das alles
selbst malen.
Draw text.
Dachte ich mir, dass das so heißt. So.
Ok. Das ist jetzt natürlich was, wo ich
gar keinen Plan habe, wie man das
gescheit macht.
Ok. Oben an der linken Ecke
Ne.
An sechster
Moment. Links
Von oben
So.
Font
Ja. Aber die haben bestimmt ein Beispiel
für.
Nö. Natürlich nicht. Font.
Graphics font type. The font to use.
Graphics font
Font
Fonts
Oh no.
Gibt es da nicht. Da muss es doch schon
irgendwie ein Default Font geben oder?
Hier. Font.
Font small. Font large.
Font medium.
Ich hoffe das tut so. Ok.
Text. Blub.
Justification.
Graphics.
Text.
Justify.
Left.
Das funktioniert doch jetzt im Leben so nicht.
Der meckert doch wieder rum, dass ich irgendwas
verkehrt gemacht
habe. Und. Error.
Cannot find Symbol Fonts.
Vielleicht ist es einfach Fonts Medium.
Graphics Fonts Medium.
Hey. Es hat funktioniert.
Bam. Vielleicht sollte ich noch die
Color vielleicht mal ändern. So.
Ne.
Es hat funktioniert Leute.
Er hat Blub gedroht.
So. Wir sollten das hier noch ändern.
Color Black.
Graphics Color.
So.
Ja. Nice. Das funktioniert.
Wir lassen es vielleicht noch.
Komm. Wir lassen es mal noch ein bisschen weiter
unten anfangen. Das sieht sonst ziemlich
beschissen aus.
Hängt so an dem Strich dran.
Ja. Ja. Sieht gar nicht mal so übel aus.
Oder? Boah. Mein Arsch läuft.
So.
Rectangle. Malen
wir jetzt eine neue.
Wir müssen das jetzt
aufsplitten. Das Ding. In drei
Unterfelder.
Unterfelder. Also.
Wir malen den Text.
Jetzt malen wir eine Rectangle.
Von links.
Ab 10 sagen wir mal.
Ja. Höhe.
Polle. Pulle.
Und
Breite. Machen wir mal
2. Das sollte reichen.
Moment. Ne. Ne. Ne.
Nicht X0.
X. X. Hier.
Ne. Wie habe ich nicht. Cell. With.
Da will ich das malen.
Ja. Das ist nur ein Simulator.
Das ist nicht das echte Gerät.
Das hat mit dem echten Gerät wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu tun.
So. Jetzt sollten wir
hier irgendwie so in der Mitte. Ja. Okay.
Schon mal nicht schlecht.
Warum auch
immer. Ach so. Moment.
Das ist der Text wo wir das anfangen.
Viertens kannst du. Kann das anfangen.
So. Das ist schon mal gar nicht so
schlecht. Die Feldhöhe.
Ja.
So. Das nächste ist.
So. Und das. Das reicht dann
eigentlich.
Jetzt müsste das. Jetzt müsste das passen.
Wir können auch Cell. With. Mal 2
machen. Das ist dann vielleicht schöner an der Stelle.
Ja.
Ja gut. Das klappt doch schon mal
ganz gut.
Mal gucken wie man das hier vielleicht zentriert oder so.
Arrow Child. Danke für den Sub.
Was die App kann.
Kann dir einen Strich anzeigen für deine
Herzfrequenz und 3 Werte anstatt
wie Garmin standardmäßig 2.
An der Stelle.
So. Das ist doch schon mal
ganz ganz nice. Oder?
Jetzt wirds. Jetzt wirds
kompliziert Leute. Also.
Ich könnte wetten. Es gibt
für sowas schon fertige Layouts
die ich innerhalb von dem
Datafield benutzen kann. Es wäre
weirdchampig wenn nicht.
Aber mal davon abgesehen. Wir können das
ja auch mal selbst zentrieren.
Ich weiß nicht ob da so spät noch meine
meine Hirnzellen für
reichen. Also wir zentrieren das erstmal
vertikal. Das heißt
wir brauchen tatsächlich
die Device Höhe.
Get.
Ja.
Äh nicht die Device Höhe. Die
Feld. Die Feldhöhe.
Brauchen wir. Das Ding bei Text
ist. Man muss jetzt erstmal wissen
wie hoch was ist.
Gibt es Get High
für Text? Gibt es sowas hier in der Richtung?
Also ich muss ja.
Ich muss dem ja sagen. Ich muss
jetzt checken wie hoch der
Get High. Ah ne Moment. Äh.
Nudel mit Lachs. Der
kommt immer rechts oben her. Kommt übers
ganze Device. Weil ihr werdet gleich sehen
das funktioniert sonst nicht.
Das funktioniert
nicht. Ich hab zwar die Höhe. Aber wenn
ich jetzt sage zum Beispiel.
Sagen wir mal die. Ich will
den Text malen. Angefangen
von
also ich von
Device Höhe
durch 2. So.
Das kommt ungefähr hin. Aber
nicht so richtig.
Ihr werdet sehen der Text ist ein bisschen unter
unterhalb der Mitte. Weil ich
muss die Mitte vom Text
eigentlich noch dazu rechnen.
Guckt. Es ist
halbwegs zentriert. Aber die Mitte
vom Text. Also ich müsste mir ausgeben
lassen können. Wie hoch der Text
ist. Davon die Mitte nehmen.
Und hier nochmal drauf rechnen.
Dann wäre da. Also
Minus. Abziehen müsste ich das. Oder?
Ne. Drauf rechnen.
Also ich müsste plus.
Das hier.
Plus. Ja. Ich weiß nicht
wie hoch der Text ist. Das heißt wie kriegt man.
Wie kriegt man. Ne 3 in Error
bringt dir nix in dem Fall.
Weil du hast ja unterschiedliche
Device Höhe.
Get Text with in Pixel.
Haben wir auch sowas wie
Get Text
Hier.
Dimensions.
Ja. Ja.
Text Dimensions. Genau das brauche ich.
Get Text
Dimensions. Und
von wo? Von DC?
Wo
aus? System.
Rindeln.
DC. Get
Get Text Dimensions.
Und dann.
Ok. String.
Und Font.
Nicht Font.
Ist ja kein
Stonks. Ok.
Nice. Jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt. Da was sinnvolles
bei rauskommt. Ja.
Passt.
Das ist die Höhe. 19.
Also. Wir brauchen
Text Dimension.
Text Dimension. So.
Plus.
Das zweite ist die Höhe.
Und das auch nochmal durch
2. So. Und jetzt
sollte der Text.
Ich hoffe das rundet automatisch für
mich. Das ich da nix machen muss.
Zum nächsten Pixel.
Weil halbe Pixel gibt es halt nicht.
So. Und jetzt sollte der Text
genau zentriert sein.
Ne.
Chatge
habe ich irgendwie.
Moment. Ich will Minus.
Minus. Nicht Plus.
Minus. Ja. Fast.
Hier. Perfection.
Das sieht übrigens
falsch aus. Es ist aber nicht falsch.
Wir müssen am Ende noch
die 4 Pixel für den grünen Strich
oben drauf rechnen.
Plus. Hier.
Und dann ist es
Top.
Top aligned.
Also. Perfekt aligned.
Ja. Zack. Exakt.
In der Mitte.
So muss das sein.
Ne. So.
Und jetzt kommt das nächste.
Wie kriegen wir das ganze?
Horizontal aligned.
Das müsste ja von der Idee her ähnlich
sein. Oder?
Das scheint aber the way
zu sein. Ja.
Draw line. Font.
Top row. Bottom row.
Ja. Ja.
Im Prinzip macht der das ähnlich. Ne.
Ah. Moment.
Der macht Text aligned. Center.
Ja. Das ist natürlich
Three hat, dass ich das
nicht mache. Da kann ich mir das
Zentrieren sparen.
Moment. Text aligned.
Text. Justify.
Center. Moment. V center
gibt es auch?
Habe ich das richtig gesehen? Ah. Ich habe nicht gebildet.
Bild.
Jetzt ist es broken.
Ich glaube mein. Ah. Ne. Doch.
Jetzt geht er.
Ja. Das funktioniert ja nicht.
Weil.
Ich muss doch manuell centern.
Weil der aligned ist ja
an der gesamten Breite.
Der weiß ja von meinen.
Der weiß ja von meinen Feldern nichts.
Und der macht es
in rows. Ne. Ne. Ne.
Justify left.
Also müssen wir es doch
von Hand machen.
Also.
Die Breite durch zwei.
Minus.
Text dimension
null durch zwei.
So. Ist es jetzt. Leute was meint ihr?
Klappt es jetzt?
Ist es jetzt horizontal aligned?
Es ist nicht an der Stelle wo es
sein soll.
Weil ich.
Ach so. Ja. Weil die erste.
Also es ist fast richtig.
Es ist. Es ist fast richtig.
Es muss.
Oh shit.
Moment. Moment.
Es ist ja auch width. Ist ja auch falsch.
Es muss ja auch sell.
Sell width durch zwei sein.
Aber man sieht das das
Zentrieren prinzipiell funktioniert.
Ja. Hä?
Das ist nice.
Schön gesentert hier.
Wir tun jetzt einfach mal so.
Als wäre das jetzt hier die Uhrzeit.
So.
Fake Uhrzeit.
Wobei. Wie kriegt man denn die Uhrzeit überhaupt?
Time.
Oder Clock.
Get clock time.
Get the current clock time.
Okay.
Garmin.
System. Get clock time.
Ach hier. Da kann man das Format.
Naja. Das machen wir jetzt nicht.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal fake Daten rein.
Äh. Wait a minute.
Sollte da jetzt nicht.
Zehn. Fünf.
Au. Au. Au. Au. Au.
Moment Leute.
Das ist richtig.
PPGaTime.
N45.
Wie? Schwer kann sowas für eine Honor
Smartwatch sein. Das ist Android oder?
Wahrscheinlich.
Bei komplexen Sachen einfacher.
Bei einfachen Sachen schwieriger.
Weil du erst noch eine Android App bauen musst dafür.
Das ist cool.
Das ist nice. Das gefällt mir. Das ist tatsächlich relativ easy.
So.
Bei dem ersten zeigen wir die Uhrzeit an.
Bei dem zweiten.
Ich meine ich zeige jetzt irgendwelche Fake Werte an.
So. Bei dem zweiten zeige ich.
Keine Ahnung.
Prozent der Steigung an.
Oder irgendwie sowas.
Wir müssen eine Schleife über einen Array machen.
Wie macht man.
Okay. Okay.
Monkey C.
For each.
Kann das sowas?
Loop.
0++ und so.
While.
For each gibt es nicht oder?
Äh.
For each ist outdated.
Overrated.
Das möchte er nicht.
Wir wollen ja 3
Datenfelder haben.
So. For each.
So. Machen wir mal hier.
Ähm.
Ich hoffe man macht das so.
Also.
Values.
10 Uhr 45.
15% Steigung.
Und. Tja.
Speed. Speed. Keine Ahnung.
24,5.
Weiß gar nicht.
Wie zeigt ein Garmin standardmäßig den Speed an?
Ja.
KMH so untereinander.
Nee das ist gar nicht Garmin.
Doch hier. Ja.
Gucken.
Die haben bestimmt irgendeinen Unit Helper.
Die haben bestimmt irgendeinen Unit.
Unit Helper für sowas.
Machen wir das einfach mal so.
Values. So. Values. Size.
War. Value. Gleich.
Values. Äh.
I. So jetzt müssen wir das nämlich
hier irgendwie mal reinpacken.
Sonst wird das zu
zu pepega.
Also. Okay.
Value.
Jetzt mal gucken ob das prinzipiell funktioniert
noch was ich hier baue.
Build. Error.
Miss. Was?
Input for. Expecting.
What?
Alter ich hab das legit 1 zu 1.
Achso. Okay ich hab nix gesagt.
Das ist einfach nur pepega
Fehlermeldung.
Ups.
Okay es funktioniert. Natürlich sind
die Felder noch nicht an der richtigen Stelle.
Das müssen wir jetzt ausrechnen.
Das müssen wir jetzt
ausrechnen. Also.
Chatgear. Da müsst ihr mir mal mit eurem
Five Header Chat
Schwarmintelligenz helfen.
Wie rechnen wir jetzt das passende
Die passende
Position aus für den
Also. Das hier bleibt immer
gleich.
Die vertikale Zentrierung.
Das ist easy.
Das können wir so lassen. Aber das hier ist
tatsächlich ein bisschen komplizierter.
Also.
Es ist
Cell width
Mal I
Oder?
Also das erste ist dann halt
Das erste ist dann halt 0 durch
2 ist 0.
Das ist nicht so ganz richtig.
Aber wir können ja mal prinzipiell
gucken ob es dann für die anderen funktionieren
würde.
Beim ersten hat er wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Probleme.
Äh. Ne.
Pepega
Five Heads Low IQ Time.
Leute was ist hier verkehrt?
Achso. Moment.
Ich weiß was verkehrt ist.
Wir machen I gleich 1.
Values
Minus 1.
Mir fällt gerade nichts anderes ein.
Jetzt müsste es doch passen. Oder?
Das geht 1.
Dann die Hälfte von
Pass auf. Pass auf. Und und
Ne.
Ok. Da bin ich eindeutig
zu dumm jetzt gerade für.
Die erste. Das erste stimmt.
Ah. Ich weiß was das Problem ist.
Plus
Ah. Plus
Das muss nicht mal
Sell with. Es muss mal
Sell with plus
Sell with sein. Oder?
Oh Mann. Jetzt playen
ich mal durch. So.
Ich hasse solche Sachen Mann.
Ja. Ne.
Oh wie ich solche Alignment Sachen
hasse ey. Da dreh ich immer durch bei.
Kennt ihr
Chasm Workspaces?
I wieder 0.
Ok. Try and Error
Time.
Ne. Ich glaub meine Logik ist noch nicht so
ganz ähm
ausgereift.
Das durch 2 ist das Problem.
Warte mal.
Ja. Tatsächlich.
Das durch 2
ist. Ok.
Jaja. Jaja. Moment. Es ist immer.
Moment. Es ist immer
Sell with durch 2.
Ne. Moment Leute. Es ist immer
Weil die Dinger sind immer gleich breit.
Und ich möchte es immer.
Sell with durch 2 ist immer die Mitte.
Ja. Also. Also
das hier
für sich genommen
ist schon mal richtig.
Das hier ist immer die Mitte
minus
der Text.
Allerdings ist nur
die Frage wo er anfängt.
Und eigentlich müsste es
wahrscheinlich. Ja.
Müsste Sell with dann pro
Schleifen durch. Also pro
Schleifendurchlauf 1 hochgehen.
Das passt jetzt noch nicht genau.
Aber es sollte für
1 und 2 passen.
Ja.
Das ist schon mal gut.
Und jetzt
mal i.
Das funktioniert beim ersten nicht.
Aber danach.
Jetzt haben wir es irgendwie.
Jetzt haben wir es irgendwie zerstört.
Easy as fuck.
Easy. Easy.
Okay.
Einmal ordentlich drüber nachgedacht und schon
funktioniert es.
Das finde ich sehr gut.
Excellent ist das.
Excellent.
Exquisite.
Five hat time.
Ja. Das ist doch schon mal
nice oder?
Morgen muss ich mir angucken wie ich das
sideloaded bekomme auf meinen Fahrradcomputer.
Kann es bestimmt per USB
anschließen das Ding und drauf sideloaden. Ohne.
Ohne Connect IQ Store
oder sonst was.
Das finde ich. Das finde ich sehr, sehr nice.
Hm. Natürlich ist hier
gerade nichts dynamisch dran.
Das ist ja klar.
Tatsächliche Werte anzeigen.
Ja.
Können wir machen. Also.
Nehmen wir mal beispielsweise hier die
die Steigung
die man gerade unterwegs ist.
Wie great. Ne weiß ich gar nicht
wie man das rauskriegt.
Ja oder.
Elevation. Wie schreibt man
Elevation?
Oh.
Methods.
Elevation. Great.
Oh.
Da ist halt die Frage wie man das
auswertet.
Get Elevation
History. Ne das will ich nicht.
Ich will eigentlich Sensor.
Hier Sensor. Was haben wir denn da?
Sensor Info.
Ne Altitude
müsste es dann wenn schon sein.
Altitude.
Ok.
Hm.
Also sofern ich diese
Garmin Dinger irgendwie gecheckt habe.
Da müsste es quasi sowas sein
wie. Ja sowas wie
Sensor.
Ne. Get
Bin ich verwirrt? Was?
Sensor Info.
On Sensor. What?
Ok. Sensor Get Info.
Ist es dann. Get Info.
Also wenn ich die
Garmin Sachen irgendwie halbwegs gecheckt
habe. Sensor. Get Info.
Und jetzt.
Altitude.
Wahrscheinlich brauche ich noch Permissions dafür.
Ja.
Permission Sensor.
Ja. Dachte ich mir.
Sensor.
Ja. Save.
Nein nein nein nein. Build.
Successful. Jawoll.
Reload.
Guck mal. Vielleicht. Vielleicht.
Vielleicht reicht das ja schon.
Oh no. Get Info not
available to data fields.
Ok.
Dann muss man das irgendwie anders
auswählen.
Ich meine. Die echten
Werte anzeigen ist ja
nur noch eine Formsache
mit dem man raus bekommt wo man die
herkriegt. Ja.
Also anscheinend geht das so in einem
Data Field schon mal nicht.
Wie kriegt man sonst noch die Höhe?
Activity Info.
Ja.
Das ist doch gut. Die haben wir doch schon.
Die haben wir doch schon.
Activity Info.
Ja.
Ja. Dann machen wir das mal anders hier.
Activity Info.
Heart Rate.
Current Heart Rate.
Haben wir das da weg?
Ah.
Alt.
So. Genau.
Und jetzt.
Wenn ich hier irgendwo was vergessen habe.
Ein Build
Successful.
Jetzt sollte das funktionieren.
Sofern er nicht wieder irgendwas zu meckern hat.
Gucken wir mal.
Ob er abkackt oder nicht.
Moment.
Habe ich noch Get Info irgendwo drin?
Ach fast.
By the way.
Warum bricht immer das Run
ab?
Oder nicht immer. Manchmal.
So. Brage.
Was?
Expected String. Given Float.
Okay.
Ähm.
Wie caste ich
nen Float zu nem String?
S String?
Fragezeichen.
Okay. Anscheinend.
Ja.
Das geht aber wahrscheinlich so netter.
Und?
Hahaha.
Expected String. Given Float.
Wie jetzt?
Das ist Monkey C.
Das eigene von Garmin.
Okay. Garmin SDK.
Float to String.
Float.
To String. Moment.
Format.
Prozent.
Okay.
Format.
Prozent.
Prozent D.
Vielleicht. Ja. Ja.
Okay.
Moment.
War ein bisschen zu naheliegend.
Was?
Heiz. Moment.
So nicht. Run.
Ja.
Wir sind auf Tau 1079 Meter.
Leute.
Falls ihr das noch nicht wusstet.
Das ist nice. Also. Chat.
Was sagt ihr?
Für die allerersten Gehversuche mit dem Garmin SDK gar nicht mal schlecht.
Und ich muss sagen.
brauchbaren Emulator.
Die Sprache ist jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt
mein Favorit, aber
geht irgendwie auch
noch ganz gut klar.
Oh, das können wir alles löschen.
Das werden wir eh nicht verwenden.
Also das... Ich dachte auch
nicht, dass wir das alles so heute hinkriegen.
Vollkommen fein, oder?
Mit C++ wäre das
deutlich ätzender gewesen.
So viel kann ich schon mal sagen.
Ja, die Dokumente sind nicht so geil,
aber immerhin. Ich meine, man
kommt halbwegs durch.
Ich denke, das kann man so lassen.
Ich werde das mal morgen
Just for Fun sideloaden auf
meinen Fahrradcomputer. Vielleicht machen wir
das auch im Stream. Und dann gucken wir
das uns mal mit echten Werten an.
Allerdings ohne, dass ich meine GPS-Position
leake.
Aber schon mal praktisch.
Gefällt mir echt gut.
Jetzt müssen wir nur noch gucken.
Das machen wir aber nicht heute.
Unit.
Hier.
Distance-Unit.
Weil
dieses Kilometer pro Stunde,
diese...
Was ist denn eine Complication?
Kann mir das irgendjemand erklären?
Subscribe and publish
to Complication.
Weil
man braucht ja garantiert...
Also es muss irgendwo den Unit-Text
und so zum Malen geben.
Das kann nicht sein,
dass man das selbst machen muss.
Also ein Widget.
Okay.
Weil guckt,
wie das hier Garmin malt,
die schreiben hier KMH so.
Und das gibt es doch garantiert
schon fertig.
Als
so irgendwie
drawable.
Da muss man mal gucken hier.
Text, da kann man garantiert
irgendeine Unit
direkt
drawen lassen.
Das muss bestimmt nicht jeder Data-Fielder
entwickler.
Denn eigene, eigene Einheiten malen.
Gibt es bestimmt schon irgendwas Fertiges.
Okay.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Reicht für heute.
Wir haben wirklich was auf die Reihe gekriegt.
Ich bin begeistert.
Das ging, das ging wirklich ernsthaft jetzt deutlich angenehmer, als ich mir das gedacht
habe.
Guck mal und sogar, sogar die Puls-Anzeige funktioniert.
Ich werde jetzt nicht mehr so viel reden.
Ich werde jetzt pennen gehen.
Bett getimed.
Boomer müde, Boomer schlafen.
Bis die Tage, Leute.
Macht's gut.
Bis denn.
Cu.
Ja, mal wieder endlich, endlich mal Proggas Bastel streamen.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut.
Cu.